elle est folle d'abord on va croire que
c'est qu'aucun parce qu'elle est encore
rapport au sexe bah on souhaite qu'aucun
bon d'ailleurs vous étiez meilleurs
qu'eux a en effet et comme chargé les
maisons faut c'est vrai mais il s'est
tout cela incroyable d'excusés à
quelqu'un tu es au courant lendemain tu
l'appelles j'aime et des capteurs de
votre slip à leur écoute bien parce que
l'histoire est vraie elle est vraiment
folle en coïncidant sur quelque chose
un samedi soir je vais en boîte de nuit
y'avait pas d'expo jour là tous les
soirs
jean beaudoin givet hockey jarrier ou
non rémunérée 70 non non non non non
rémunéré pas j'arrive à l'aller les gens
voient la stèle d'une star arrivée bon
breton annan a appelé vous une soirée
thématique c'est toi oui tu peux donc
pas eu d'aidé jean dobey dire en quoi
les oubliez pas il ya pas beaucoup de
filles ouf ouf
non c'est une soirée gay j'arrive et
c'est vrai qu'il va y avait le choix est
donc je décide de faire plaisir à
quelqu'un j'en choisis un très très beau
je ne fais donc était très très beau ça
viendra je ne ramène à la maison et ça
se passe très bien
oui tu étais vraiment très très beau et
du coup deux jours après je me retrouve
à un dîner chez des amis à paris et du
coup un peu fier de ma trouvaille je
monte mon téléphone et j'ai dû boire
tous les cas l'autre jour j'ai quelques
cas mais un truc maigreur des photos
quand c'était pas plus sur ce point et
photos oui bah oui mais pas pendant le
double c'est plutôt pourquoi c'est pour
la police après semaine et je montre à
table la photo de ma prise n'ont été si
sa table j'avais deuxième il est 4
heures je connaissais pas je te jure qu
histoire est vraie la prob est
impossible je le montre parmi les quatre
qui restent était son mec
non mais voilà il est tellement dans le
rôle qu'il a revécu l'histoire comme ça
fait sens commun et donc la maison
s'élever quoi il a quitté le dîner il
est parti non
we do qui passe il étonne qu'à cet égard
c'est plus costaud
[Applaudissements]